one day if human civilization ever wipes
itself out aliens or one of our
successors will cast an eye on our
ruined planet
and ask themselves what ever happened to
Homo sapiens their answer might look a
little like this the root cause won't be
the specific catastrophe conflict or
devastation that eradicate sus the
problem will begin with the architecture
of the human brain this tool will be
remembered for being in part deeply
impressive containing a hundred billion
neurons capable of extraordinary
computations and combinations as aliens
will note a particular part of the mind
where our most dazzling thoughts
unfolded was known to neuro scientists
as the neocortex a part that in humans
was many times larger than that found in
any other species this is what helps
this hugely clever ape to produce the
Magic Flute and a Karenina
conquered and civilization however our
alien friends will also note that the
human mind contained another component
very influential but far less impressive
known as the reptilian brain an
aggressive lustful impulsive section of
machinery with a great deal more in
common with what might be found in a
hyena or a small rodent because of this
reptilian brain Homo sapiens ended up
with three grave problems firstly
tribalism humans were always on the
verge of developing violent hatreds of
foreigners and manifested strong ongoing
tendencies to slaughter strangers in
vast numbers they could never reliably
see the humanity in all members of their
own kind secondly Homo sapiens was
fatefully prone to short-term thinking
even when confronted by data it could
only imagine the near-term future a few
years at best viewing the long-term as a
chimerical an unreal state its immediate
impulses were left uncontained and
worked to destroy its individual and
collective future
lastly Homo sapiens had an especially
keen fondness for wishful thinking
though capable of immense intellectual
achievement its mind hated to reflect on
itself it couldn't bear to submit its
ideas to rational scrutiny it preferred
to act rather than think and daydream
rather than plan having invented the
scientific method it preferred in most
cases just not to use it it had a
narcotic desire for distraction and
fantasy it didn't want to know itself
for many generations these three floors
were more or less endured certain
institutions were invented to attenuate
them the law sound government education
philosophy science it worked sort of
humans did keep wiping out swathes of
their fellows but they didn't scupper
the species as a whole what caused the
ultimate destruction was the increasing
yet untrammeled power of the neocortex
this mighty tool eventually managed to
capture fire contain the elements and
give Homo sapiens a god-like power over
the planet while the animal overall
still operated with reflexes a serene
and gentle as those of a hyena the cost
of its mistakes grew ever larger its
powers became uncontained while its
wisdom remained intermittent and fragile
eventually its might outpaced its
capacity for self-control it became a
nuclear armed rodent there was one thing
that might have saved humanity love and
three varieties of love in particular
firstly the love of the stranger the
capacity to see the other as like
oneself and worthy of the same mercy and
charity
secondly the love of the unborn the
concern for those who do not as yet
exist and whom one will never know but
whose lives one is shaping in the
selfish present thirdly the laugh of the
truth the strength to resist illusion
and lies and square up to uncomfortable
facts of all kinds we don't need to be
aliens of the future to understand all
this
we can see the disaster scenario only
too well right now the fate of
civilization lies ultimately not in the
law courts at the ballot box or in the
corridors of governments it lies in our
ability to master the most short-term
selfish violent of our impulses active
in the dense folds of organic matter
between our ears it lies in learning how
relentlessly to try to compensate for
the flawed architecture of the human
mind
you